Meine Damen und Herren, herzlich willkommen im ICE nach Köln.
Wie Sie dem Aufkleber an Ihrem Sitz, den Laufleisten auf den Monitoren und den ausgelegten Broschüren entnehmen können, befinden Sie sich im Ruhebereich. Aufgrund der Gerichtsentscheidung Titzloff und Will gegen Deutsche Bahn sind auch wir ab sofort verpflichtet, unsere Durchsagen akustisch anzupassen. Vielen Dank für Ihr Verständnis. Nächster Halt ist Wuppertal. Der Ausstieg ist in Fahrtrichtung rechts. Next stop Wuppertal. Thank you for choosing the Deutsche Bahn. Yes! Genau so will man's doch. Und damit herzlich willkommen. Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung 2023. Ja, wir sind wieder da. Stefan, Florentin und Danny ist mit an Bord. Vielen Dank für die gemeinsame Reise. Danny, Florentin, ich wünsche euch ein gesegnetes, frohes Neujahr. Das wissen wir nicht. Sorry, das wissen wir nicht, ob Danny auch ein gesegnetes neues Jahr. Das stimmt, wir wollen nicht für ihn sprechen.
Wir wollen nur, er steht lediglich für sein Intro, es ist wie so Wahlwerbespots. Wir haben damit
nichts zu tun und sie haben mit unserem
nationalen Heiligen. Alle nachfolgenden Sachen haben wir nichts mit zu tun.
Wir wissen nicht, ob Danny in diese religiöse Ecke
überhaupt reingeht oder will, wenn du
sagst, ein geheiligtes, gesalbtes
Jahr 2023, ich weiss auch nicht,
wie du jetzt da wieder hier ein gottesfürchtiges neues
Jahr, weihrauchtriefend hier zur Tür
reinkommst. Also klar, wir kennen
natürlich Stephans Phasen, aber das nimmt natürlich
Vielen Dank. Ja, 2023, ich weiß auch nicht, wie du jetzt da wieder hier ... Ein gottesfürchtiges neues Jahr. ... weihrauchtriefend hier zur Tür reinkommst. Also klar, wir kennen natürlich Stephans Phasen, aber das nimmt natürlich bei Neujahr immer noch mal ganz neue Dimensionen an. Also da wird hier wirklich, du kommst hier rein, gesalbt, Hostien, drei Hostien auf der Zunge. Fit, jetzt schon, Sixpack, jetzt schon. Der Jesus-Look, du hast schon wirklich schön die Apps dabei, du kennst dich aus. Nee, ich freue mich sehr, ein neues Jahr, ein neues Glück, sagt man ja. Ebenfalls wünsche ich euch allen ein frohes neues Jahr. Für Flo und den kann ich mittlerweile sprechen, da weiß ich genau, was er denkt und was er wünscht. Da habe ich dir grünes Licht gegeben. Da hat er schon bereits vorher grünes Licht gegeben, also nur so einen gelangweilten Augenrollst-Emoji und dann Thumbs-up-Emoji nach mehrmaligem Nachhaken. Er wünscht euch auch ein gesegnetes, frohes, neues Jahr. Aber sehr schönes Intro von Danny, nochmal möchte ich natürlich nochmal drauf eingehen. Aber das soll gleich so politisch starten, willst wieder. Ruheabteilpetition, nein, das bin ich. Das bin ich, das ist Florentin 2023. Ich wünsche dir, du wirst mehr. Ja, und das bin ich jetzt auch. Ich prangere an, ich bin politisch, ich weise auf die Missstände dieser Welt hin. Und an allererster Stelle, bevor ich mich um irgendwas anderes kümmern kann, muss das erstmal vom Schreibtisch. Natürlich, Ruheabteil, die Petition läuft und ich will die 2023 in den Bundestag bringen. Ich will da mal richtig was aufrühren. Bei jeder Weise, dass du so geordnet arbeitest, dass du immer nur eine Sache auf dem Schreibtisch haben kannst. Ja, klar. Du kannst nicht parallel mehrere Sachen machen. Nein, für uns ist es so geordnet, OCD kicks in, eine Sache auf dem Schreibtisch und dann wird die abgearbeitet, dann kommt das nächste. Mein Schreibtisch ist nicht so gross, wenn du da einen Leitsordner aufmachst. Nein, Dina 4 gross. Das ist sehr hoch, das ist ein Stehschreibtisch, das ist wie so ein Monolith. Es ist Dina 4 gross, damit nur ein, das fand ich eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee. Genau Genau ein Blatt Papier. Keine Unordnung, du bist auch Minimalist. Du musst fokussieren, ja. Fokussiert sein, ist Dina vier gross, passt genau ein Blatt drauf und so. Und selbst wenn es schon so gutackert ist und schlecht getackert ist, schon ein Problem. Dann rutscht es an der Seite runter, ist schon schwierig. Ist aber ein geiler Tisch, einfach Dina vier Grösse. So, jetzt mache ich mal die Buchhaltung. Ja, unterschrieben. Ich meine, das brauche ich vielleicht, um mich ein bisschen zu fokussieren, weil mir liegt dann auch da das und das. Ja, du hast dann auch wieder deinen Rubik's Cube und deinen mit den Kugeln hin und her und so und dann drückst du dein Gesicht da rein. Kleiner Kaktus, ja, dieses kleine Kaktus. Dieses Gesichtssding mit diesen vielen Nadeln. Was du so abarbeiten musst. Stell dir mal das vor, du kommst so ins Büro, setzt dich hin, so, einmal einmal die Newtonkugeln, dann einmal die... Du lachst nämlich gerade, ich bin viel genervt, ich komme morgens rein, habe gar keinen Bock auf, erstmal Newtonkugeln, Rubik's Kipp lösen, dann das Gesicht, mein Gesicht in dieses Ding drücken. Dann so ein Papierknödel in den Basketballkorb über Mülleimer werfen. Stefan, könntest du ganz kurz die Zahlen? Nein, du siehst doch... Ich bin gerade mittendrin, siehst du es nicht. Ich drehe mich um mit meinem Gesicht in diesen Nadeldingen und drehe mich so um und sage,
ich habe das Nadelgesicht, hat so böse Augen.
Oder spricht so mega genervt.
Du siehst doch, was ich gerade mache.
Oh, Entschuldigung, Herr Tietze, ich wusste nicht, dass Sie gerade beschäftigt. Nee, also jetzt ins neue Jahr dann direkt so zu starten.
Und dann ist es natürlich gefährlich, wenn man zu Weihnachten was Neues kriegt, weil
das, Gott, jetzt muss ich auch meine, jetzt muss ich auch noch diese kleine Metallwippe da auch noch andrehen. Gott, Solitär. Gott. Er ist schwierig, aber... Aber lustig, dass du davon sprichst, weil ich bin gestern im Zug nach Hause nach Köln gekommen und es war, also ha, weil Ruheabteil ist ja, ne, Stille und das andere Abteil, so lacht ihr nämlich, wenn ihr im Podcast habt. Das muss man nämlich auch mal hörbar machen, das Nasenlachen. Ne, genau, weil Flonti lacht häufig bei Dingen, die man sagt, aber man hört es nicht und wir beide lachen über die ganze Zeit, aber halt manchmal die Nase. Da haben wir uns vorgenommen, dass wir das hörbar und erlebbar machen auch. Und das andere Abteil wird ja dadurch so ein bisschen zum Schnackabteil.
Ja, das stimmt.
Alle schnacken ein bisschen die ganze Zeit.
Böllerabteil im Grunde.
Diese Überfokussierung auf das Ruheabteil führt dazu, finde ich, dass die Pendelbewegung jetzt an die andere Richtung ausschlägt, gerade in meinem normalen Abteil. Und neben mir sass gestern, ist daneben eine Frau eingestiegen, eines älteren Jahrgangs, und trotz Buch und trotz meiner Kopfhörer hat sie die ganze Zeit mit mir geredet. Und ich habe bis zu einem Grad, dass ich irgendwann dachte, das kann gerade nicht wahr sein. Ich bin auch viel zu höflich und will auch zu sehr gefallen, als dass ich dann sagen würde, können Sie bitte Ihre Scheißfresse halten. Sondern ich würde dann, ich rede die ganze Zeit mit ihr und habe auch overshared mit privaten Details, weil ich so sehr, weil ich das auch irgendwann. In Tränen lagst du in ihren Armen. Ja, es war eigentlich ganz nett, aber bis auf die Tatsache, dass ich lesen wollte und Musik hören wollte und sie die ganze Zeit auf mich angeredet hat. Und dann hat sie die eine Sache gesagt, die für mich alles wieder gut gemacht hat, nämlich die einzige Erklärung, warum das okay war. Ja, sie ganze Zeit spricht. Nein, viel besser, sie hat, sie kommt von einem dreitägigen Schweigeseminar. Sie hat es gesagt und innerlich habe ich mich kaputt gelacht. Sie kam direkt von einem dreitägigen Schweigeseminar, setzt sich neben mich und plappert los. Warum auch nicht? Natürlich. Natürlich. Am Bahnsteig winkt sie noch allen und so nur mit den Lippen, steigt ein und ja, jetzt muss ich immer erzählen. Sofort. Weil es war so krass, aber auch schon erlebt, aber es ist immer wahnsinnig schlimm und es gibt keine Erklärung dafür und keine gesunde Ausrede, außer wirklich dreitiges Schweigeseminar. Das ist das Letzte, was du hören willst. Steigst ins Flugzeug ein und von wo kommen Sie her? Von einem siebenmonatigen Schweigekloster. Okay, Kopfhörer aus, abnehmen. Ja, dann erzählen Sie mal. Aber ist das denn die Idee eines Schweigeseminars, dass man sich einfach alles merkt, was man sagen will, um dann einfach der nächsten Abend Seele-Lawin-artig das alles drüber zu stülpen? Ich glaube, ich wurde Zeuge eines Jojo-Effekts, nur nicht nach einer Diät, sondern nach einer Schweigediät, sagen wir mal. Ja, verstehe. Also einer Wortdiät und ich wurde halt Zeuge, wie dann plötzlich der Rebound kam. Ein Wort Heisshunger quasi. Genau. Ja. Und ja, es wurdeert, fleissig. Leider bis zu einem, wenn irgendwann, ja, hat sie dann Sachen gesagt wie, sie will sich nicht impfen lassen, sie glaubt, es nervt sie, dass mittlerweile 6G existiert, nicht mehr pfeift die ganzen LTE-Masten. Und deswegen trägt sie ein Kristall um den Hals, damit die Schwenkungen, also es wurde irgendwann in so eine Esoterik-Ecke abgedriftet. Aber meinst du mit 6G dieses Geimpft, Genesen, Geheilt oder ist das die Technologie ... Geimpft, Genesen, Geheilt, Gefickt. Ja und jetzt muss man ja auch noch verschiedenste G sein. Nee, da ist sie dann schlagartig auf die LTE-Masten zu sprechen gekommen. Da geht es dann doch um die Sendemasttechnologie.
Es ging um die Sendemasttechnologie, es ging um die Corona-Propaganda. Dann hat sie gesagt, wenn die... Was haben die denn immer mit diesen Masten? Also wirklich gegen alle Dinge in der Welt, gegen die man sein kann, aber dass man da wirklich gegen diese Mobilfunk-Masten ist. Ja, vor allem, das muss ähnlich für Sie gewesen sein, wie wenn ich neben einer Frau sitze, die die ganze Zeit redet, müsste für sie gewesen sein, wie ich dann mit meiner Hochtechnologie neben mir sitze, mit meinem 7G ballernden iPhone 11, dann meinen AirPods und so. Ich denke mir, das ist für sie wahrscheinlich auch der Horror. Er trug einen Kristall um ihren Hals, um sie vor diesen Schwingungen zu bewahren, deswegen passiert ihr nichts. Da habe ich gesagt, ja okay, dann kann ich ja hier mit meinem Handy sitzen bleiben, ist ja alles gut.
Zum Glück.
Ja, also dann kam dann irgendwann viel Quatsch raus.
Ich kann mir, also nichts gegen diese Frau, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie vielleicht irgendwie zu Weihnachten oder zum Geburtstag mal von ihrer Familie einen Gutschein bekommen hat für ein Schweigeseminar, dass man sagt, ach weißt du, sag mal, ich glaube, dir würde es mal richtig gut tun, wenn du mal drei Tage lang nichts sagst, weil es ist ja schwer, es ist vielleicht die Oma oder so, da kommst du jetzt mit Argumenten nicht weiter, die einzige Chance, die du hast, ist das Schweigeseminar und dieses Seminar will ich sehen, wo alle Leute ihre problematischen Verwandten hinschicken, die mal einfach die fucking Klappe halten wollen, bitte kurz. Wo man dann nicht weiß, verstehen die sich jetzt besonders gut, weil das alles die problematischen Verwandten sind? Aber sie sagen nichts, erkennt man sich auch so. Ja genau, das war eine alte Jerry Seinfeld-Frage, weil er irgendwann festgestellt hat, dass George Costanzers Eltern mit seinen nicht klarkommen. Und er dachte, this is a thing, weil die sind doch alle weird und alt und die dachten, die sind in ihrem Kosmos weird und alt, aber selbst da können die sich hassen, weil die andere Eltern noch seltsamer finden als sich selbst. Ja, ja, okay, also der 9-11-Truther und der Corona-Leugner passen dann trotzdem nicht zusammen, obwohl man denkt, das würde umgepassen. Ja, aber du hast schon, also ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Geschenk war, weil deswegen habe ich es auch erzählt, gerade mit dem Kristall und diesen Sendemasten, weil ich finde, das passt schon ganz gut in dieses Schweigekloster, diese Ecke, aber es ist vielleicht auch jetzt ein Klischee, aber es ist alles so eine, zu so einem Grad eh so Ecke, dass ich schon verstehe, und bei diesem Schweigeseminar geht es ja nicht um das Experiment, Experimentswillen, sondern es geht ja schon darum, sein Ego zu besiegen, weil das, was spricht in deinem Kopf und was du auch sagst, ist ja das Ego zum Schweigen bringen und so. Da konnte ich mir gestern so ein bisschen so ein Ted-Talk anhören, aber ich glaube, das passt schon für mich so ein bisschen, vielleicht verkürzt sich das auch doof im Kopf, aber diese Sendemastenangst. Das ist aber spannend eigentlich. Also ich denke mir sofort, wie könnte es ein Film sein oder eine Serienfolge? Ich denke mir sofort erst Schweigeseminar und zwei verlieben sich aneinander. Und halt total romantisch, weil man sich gar nicht spricht, sondern nur über Körper oder Tanzen oder sowas. Was ich jetzt als Produzent bei diesem Pitch denke, ist, du bist so faul, Dialog zu schreiben. Auch. aber schauen Sie mal. Aber vielen Dank, dass Sie sich abstreiten. Nein, nein, nein, Mr. Warner, Mr. Warner, hören Sie mich an. Schauen Sie mal, Sie sparen sich ja die Kosten für die Synchronisation in anderen Ländern. Also Sie müssen ja nicht synchronisieren. Weiter. Ja, also Sie können das ja in Japan veröffentlichen, in China, in Belarus. Andere Länder, ich will alle Länder aufgezählt bekommen. In Dänemark, Sie können das ja überall raushauen, ohne dass sie synchronisieren müssen. Und jetzt kommt aber der Twist. Die beiden verlieben sich ineinander irgendwie nur so durch Blicke und gerade dieses reizvolle, ah, mag sie mich auch, mag er mich auch, weil man redet ja nicht, man kann sich nichts bestätigen, es sind immer nur Blicke und dann aber ist das Seminar vorbei und dann sprechen die nicht dieselbe Sprache oder haben eine komische Stimme oder so. Ja, genau, ja, ja, oder sowas so. Ja, wenn wir uns noch einmal hier treffen. Und dann Credits. Forever, forever, we need to be together, Ivy. Könnt ihr euch privat treffen? Und die sagt, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, dam, dam, dam, dam, Ende. Schlagartig. Ja, exakt, das finde ich super. Also, ich habe dann auch gefragt, okay, es war keine Kommunikation erlaubt. Sie hat Kommunikation gesagt, sie hat nicht Sprechen gesagt, deswegen war meine Frage, kann man denn so mit wilden Gesten und Pantomime... Kann der Mensch denn überhaupt nicht kommunizieren? Geht das denn überhaupt? Genau, das war die implizierte Frage und sehr gesagt, das soll man auch nicht, man soll generell jede Form von Kommunikation sein lassen.
Außer bei, es wurden sich schnelle frohe neue Jahre ausgetauscht, um zwölf Uhr.
Moment, man war über Silvester in einem Schweigeseminar. Sie war über Silvester, ja, sie war die letzten drei Tage da.
Alle zehn runter um dich herum.
Kann man mit Händen dann runterziehen.
Zehn, vier, drei.
Aber dann halt mehr Geräusche.
Mehr Geräusche.
Ich glaube, mit Geräuschen kann man eh viel machen.
Ich will im neuen Jahr weniger sprechen,
ich will mehr Geräusche machen.
Das wird natürlich jetzt euch Podcast-Hörer
wahrscheinlich auf dem falschen Fuß erwischen,
weil man natürlich dann viel so Aber weil du die sonst unterdrückst? Weil du gerade in so einem Alter bist, wo man eh viel Geräusche macht? Jetzt kommt alles raus. Ich bin wie so ein Schlaffer Luftballon, wo am Ende hast du ja so einen fein hohen Ton und das ist die Jugend und dann gegen Ende wird es eher so da bin ich gerade so einfach alle der Damm bricht, es ist alles so labbrig und es kommt so raus mit so kennt man ja, wenn der Damm bricht, ist es ja eher ein labbriges, leichtes Phänomen, es ist nicht auf den Damm an, es kommt mal wieder auf den fucking Damm an, dass ich diesen Satz schon wieder hören muss jetzt. Es gibt Dämme, die haben wirklich hinter sich kaum Wasser und brechen trotzdem. Aber ich finde, Januar ist unglaublich traurig und ich wünsche uns allen Kraft. Ich wünsche uns allen Kraft. Januar ist für mich einer der schlimmsten Monate. Also wirklich Top, unten Flop, Flop drei, weil der ist so scheiße, weil der ist immer noch so dunkel und so kalt und kacke wie Dezember und Oktober zum Beispiel, aber du hast nicht diesen Fun, diesen Fun-Tage. Du hast nicht Weihnachten, du hast nicht irgendwie so Tradition, an denen man sich so... Bitte heilig drei Könige, nicht, ja? Das ist bei euch in Bayern ein Riesending. Das ist ein Riesending. Ja, hier gar nicht. Da wird schön beschriftet, die Türen werden alle beschriftet, da wird schön rumgelauft, da wird schön Blackfacing betrieben, das ist ein herrlicher bayerischer Feiertag.
Aber es ist herrlich und es gibt gar nichts darüber zu diskutieren oder in Frage zu stellen von dem, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Also ich will mich jetzt auch auf nichts stürzen im Kleinen, aber man sollte Türen nicht einfach beschriften, wenn die Leute es nicht wollen, okay?
Also vielleicht kann ich vorher abchecken, ob es geht, weil sonst ist es Beschädigung fremden Eigentums, Eigentum ist. Und da aber ganz kurz, weil Larry David kennen wir alle, Kirby Enthusiasm, quasi unser Alltagsprophet, unser Alltagsgelehrter, an dem man sich wenden kann, wurde mal gefragt, wie lange darf man frohes neues Jahr wünschen. Genau. Und er hat an eine gute definierte Antwort gegeben, hat gesagt, 6. Januar, nachher das Ende. Danach gibt es kein frohes neues Jahr mehr. Ich finde, wir können in katholischer Tradition das noch bis Heilig Drei Könige ausweiten. Ich glaube, das ist ursprünglich die Idee dieses Feiertags, dass man weiß, ab da ist dann wirklich neues Jahr. Aber 6. Januar ist der. Ist der nicht 16.?
Nee, 6. Januar.
Scheiße. Das ist viel zu früh.
Kein einziges Geschenk.
Noch keine einzige Myrre.
Nein, warte mal. Heilig.
So, jetzt Achtung, wir schmeißen unsere Rechner an.
6. Januar, 6. Januar.
Ach geil. Nee, passt nicht. Larry David viel früher, als ich schon dachte, dass er das schon einkalkuliert hat. Ich war irgendwie bei 16. Deswegen 6. Januar, der heilige Tag des Ab jetzt wünscht man kein frohes neues Jahr mehr. Sehr früh, sehr früh. Also heute ist ... Moment mal. Der Tag des Folgenrelease ist nach. Wir haben unsere eigene Regel gebrochen.
Nee, aber deswegen, ich bin für den 13. ab dem 13. hat man das nicht mehr zu machen. Das soll nicht in der christlichen Tradition jetzt plötzlich den 13. mit reinbringen. Doch, Mitte des Monats, aber da kippst du langsam. Siegenfuss, ich kann deine Füsse nicht sehen. Das ist übrigens auch die Regel, wenn ihr in Beziehungen steckt, die man künstlich aufrechterhalten hat, weil man nicht an Weihnachten oder vor Weihnachten Schluss machen kann. Und dann hängt man bei den Familien ab oder aufeinander. Man hat auch schon Silvesterpläne, kann man auch schlecht Schluss machen, wenn man auch nicht Silvester verhauen. Man kann aber auch nicht am 1. Januar direkt Schluss machen, weil dann wäre so offensichtlich, dass alles davor gefakt war. Auch da ist der Dreizehnte, finde ich. Das passt aber wieder gut zu dem Umblickstag. Markiert euch den Dreizehnten für mich, also gerne, gross, weil meine Regel wäre ab da kein frohes neues Jahr mehr wünschen und Beziehungen, die künstlich über die Feiertage aufrecht erhalten wurden, können schlaghaltig beendet werden, weil, bear in mind, es folgt dann auch irgendwann Valentinstag. Ja, ja, ja. Leute, ihr seid in so ein Netz gefangen. Ihr hangelt euch vom Valentinstag, von Silvester, Weihnachten zu Geburtstag, und dann ist dann plötzlich wieder ihr Geburtstag, und dann ist wieder Weihnachten. Also irgendwann hängt ihr, und dann habt ihr plötzlich zwei Kinder, und die sind unglücklich, weil die streitende Eltern haben. Und alle sind so unglücklich. Also willst du wirklich den 13. Januar zum internationalen Schlussmachttag machen? Schlussmachttag und... Willst du wirklich sagen, das ist ja furchtbar, wenn das sich wirklich etabliert und dann denkt man immer, ja scheiße, in zwei Tagen, weil dann hast du ja das gleiche Problem wieder. Du machst nur heute Schluss, weil heute Schlussmachttag ist, so dieses Valentinstag-Problem. Warum bist du nur heute zu mir nett? Ach genau. Dann beginnt wieder das Problem, man kann nicht am Schlussmachttag Schluss machen, weil man ist eine basic ass bitch. Du müsstest eine Woche später Schluss machen, da gibt es den zweiten Ordnungsschlussmachttag. Schwierig, schwierige Situation. Aber für mich jetzt mal, klar, das sind die Probleme, die dann folgen, werden mittelbar, unmittelbar wäre ich erstmal dafür zu sagen, lass uns das so machen. Ist das dein zweites Wunder offiziell? Also ist Sankt Stefan weiter auf der Jagd, will du einerseits den Tag im November haben und den internationalen Schlussmachttag? Mit dem will ich nichts zu tun haben. Ich möchte namentlich nicht mit dem in Verbindung gebracht werden. Ich will, dass jemand mit dir an dem Tag Schluss macht und du einfach so, nein, was habe ich getan, was habe ich angerichtet? Das ist meine Idee. Es liegt doch alles gut. Du warst die ganze Vorweihnachtszeit nur mit mir zusammen, weil man da nicht Schluss machen kann. Ich mache Schluss mit dir, weil du dir immer dumme Feiertage ausdenkst. Deswegen mache ich heute Schluss mit dir. Okay. Ne, genau. Aber ja, das wäre, finde ich die Regel. Sechster finde ich zu früh. Aber du verstehst, was ich meine. Heiliger Kündiger ist hier in NRW kein großes Ding und ich glaube auch im Rest von Norddeutschland und Ostdeutschland nicht unbedingt. Aber sag uns da gerne nochmal Bescheid, was komisch ist, weil hier in Köln, im Kölner Dom ja die Heiligen Drei Könige liegen, die Gebeine, die Gebeinchen, die Beinchen. Aber nicht alles. Hier liegen die Gebeinchen. Aber nicht alles, oder? Wo liegt denn der Rest? Was weiß ich denn, irgendwo anders? Da teilen doch nicht alles rum. Klar, natürlich, diese Reliquien sind teilweise winzig. Hast du schon mal so eine Reliquie gesehen? Das ist so ein kleiner Knochensplitter oder so ein Holzsplitter vom Christuskreuz oder so.
Ah, okay.
Und du meinst, da liegen wirklich die kompletten ...
Drei Sarakophage, dachte ich jetzt, mit den drei Heiliger Königen, Kaspar und Mälchen.
Warum werden die gemeinsam beerdigt? Das waren drei random Könige, die jeder ihr eigenes Königreich hatten, die halt sich zufällig auf dem Weg zum Heiland an der Bushaltestelle getroffen haben.
Sie können auch die beerdigt. Das waren drei random Könige, die jeder ihr eigenes Königreich hatten, die halt sich zufällig auf dem Weg zum Heiland
an der Bushaltestelle getroffen haben,
sich erkannt haben an ihrer Königsruppe und so.
Entschuldigung, jetzt muss ich doch mal ganz kurz fragen.
Sind Sie,
Entschuldigung, sind Sie der König von
Judäa tatsächlich? Wollen wir ein Foto machen?
Nein, nein, ich bin ja selber auch König. Ach so, okay.
Ich frag nur, wollen wir vielleicht einfach zusammen
den Bus nehmen, einfach, weil wir haben jetzt noch ungefähr vier Monate Reise nach Bethlehem und dann dachte ich, können wir vielleicht einfach zusammen... Reden Sie die ganze Zeit, werden Sie die ganze Zeit so viel reden? Naja, in meinem Jahr gab es jetzt ein Schweigejahr bis jetzt gerade. Sabbat, ein Sabbatjahr des Sprechens. Aber ja, genau so schrecklich. Aber du hast schon recht, ich finde nur, die Geschichte hat sie zusammengeschweißt. Ja, aber nicht so weit, dass man gemeinsam begraben wird. Das ist, finde ich, auch nochmal ein Schritt. Ach komm, da schwingt jetzt auch so viel Aberglaube mit. Wenn du tot bist, kriegst du eh nichts mehr mit. Dann kann ich auch mit dir begraben werden, wenn die Geschichte uns zusammengeschweißt hat. Ist mir doch egal, wo ich begraben bin. Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, Maria, herzlichen Glückwunsch nochmal zum Kind. Eine Sache, die beiden sind ja auch Könige, aber ich sehe mich eher schon als, also separat quasi. Ich verstehe nicht. Nicht, dass wir sagen, ich habe es jetzt schon ein paar Mal sagen, die drei heiligen Könige sind auch da. Und da wollte ich nur sagen, also wie gesagt, die beiden. Sie kamen zu dritt hier rein auch und hatten auch alle ein Geschenk dabei. Richtig, richtig, richtig. Alle, ich finde, sie sind ein ikonisches Trio, jetzt, bereits jetzt. Already a cult classic. Genau, da wollte ich ansetzen. Iconic. Weil wir haben natürlich das letzte Kamel zusammen genommen, aber davor haben wir wirklich monatelang, waren die beiden zusammen und ich separat. Aber finden Sie es nicht toll? Es findet doch so catchy, auch die Heiligen drei Könige. Ja, nee, nee, von dem PR-Standpunkt kann ich das total verstehen. Ich denke, ich habe nämlich immer Marketing studiert für zwei Semester an, für das Prisenius. Ach, wirklich? Ach, ich hatte mich eh interessiert, was Sie da vorgemacht haben, ganz toll. Und da haben Sie dann kennengelernt, den Vater, oder also? Ja, kann man so sagen, er ist mir nachts erschienen. Also ein Engel. Ach wirklich, im Seminar?
Nee, ich bin abends dann nach Hause gefahren mit der U-Bahn und dann nach Hause in mein ganz Apartment. Was ich sagen wollte, sollten wir alle drei sterben, ich würde gern separat in meinem eigenen Königreich begraben werden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt noch Geschichtsschreiber werden. Also nur, dass ich es mal gesagt habe. Nur, dass ich es mal gesagt habe. Ja, ja. Nee, nur dass, falls Sie gefragt werden, dass Sie wissen, ich bin, also sagen Sie eher zwei Könige und Balthasar, ne, also...
Hey, worum geht's? Ich bin der Josef, freut mich.
Josef, hallo, freut mich.
Hi, worum geht's denn?
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, also...
Ich werde sich an meine Frau ranmachen, ne?
Das Kind sieht auch gar nicht aus wie ich, ne, ich hab schon Angst, ne, das ist einer wie Sie, von neun Monaten.
Quatsch, Quatsch, ja, ähm, ja, also herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Neueinzug, sag ich mal, also zu ihrem, also ist ja auch ihr Heiland auf eine gewisse Art. Wie? Ist mein Baby? Unser aller Baby quasi. Nee, eigentlich ist es mein Baby. Oh. Sie mir das Geschenk geben? Ja, bitteschön. Lessen Sie vielleicht nicht die Karte. Vielleicht kann ich die Karte noch mal haben. Wollen Sie mir die vorlesen? Lesen Sie mir die vorlesen. Doch, ich insistiere. Ich insistiere, dass Sie mir die Karte vorlesen. Ist doch Unsinn. Das ist doch Quatsch. Kaspar, bitte. Oder was Melchior? Balthasar. Aber wir sind ja anscheinend eh alle drei dergleichen. Wir sind ja eh eins. Also, weil man ein Kamel zusammennimmt. Uns wurde gesagt, hier sind haufenweise Könige.
Es hieß, alle Könige der Welt kommen hier zusammen und jetzt sind wir drei.
Nee, Maria und ich haben uns bei Fresen jetzt in unserem Marketingseminar kennengelernt, PR und so.
Und da haben wir gedacht, aus dem Marketingstandpunkt wäre es doch nicht schlecht, wenn Heiligen drei kühlen. Sie sind hier erschienen nachts als Engel.
Nee, nee, ich bin Josef, ich war mit ihr im Kurs, ich saß vor ihr.
Ja.
Ich glaube, ich gehe kurz in die Küche und mache ein paar Empanadas für alle.
Josef, pass auf.
Ja, was denn?
Ist sie nicht toll?
Empanadas für alle?
Sie ist super, sie ist eine ganz, ganz tolle Frau.
Und die hat Zimtschnecken.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Nee, sie ist eine ganz tolle und ich glaube auch, dass sie eine grosse Zukunft hat.
Bei dir allerdings, also wie gesagt, sie meinte gerade, der Vater sei ihr erschienen und als Engelsform. Ja, ich bin erschienen, ich bin einfach in den Raum gekommen, ich war irgendwann der Neue, der hotte Neue, der reinkam und wo alle Zeitlupe reinkamen, wie in jeder Raum kommen, Coming-of-Age-Filme. Meint ihr das mit erschienen? Ich meine, hat sie das
Das Kind sieht nicht aus wie ich. Was implizieren
sie gerade? Naja, ich sag mal so,
es ist dir nicht aufgefallen, dass ein riesiger Stern über
der Scheune ist, dass hier Leute kommen. Ja, es ist arschhell.
Ich mache nachts kein Auge zu.
Ja, und das alles, weil du so ein krasser Typ
bist oder was? Ich bin ja niemand, ich bin Tischler. Was glaubst du denn?
Ja, eben. Ich hab's abgebrochen
in meinem Studium, bin Tischler geworden. Zimmermann,
glaube ich.
Ah, ja, deswegen diese schönen Zimmer hier, wunderbar. Sehen Sie die Ornamente? Schauen Sie doch die Zeichen an, Mensch, Sie haben doch nichts zu tun mit dem Kind. Wissen Sie was? Sie Arschloch, Sie werden begraben mit diesem Heini da hinten und dem anderen Heini. Nein, nein, nicht in Köln, nicht in Kölle. Weihnachtsgex, wir machen immer noch Weihnachtsgags. Darf man bis 16. Januar, darf man. Wie lange hängt Weihnachts-Doku, Deko? Nein Mutter, Deko, nicht Doku. Ach so, und sie mit so einer Kamera, die die ganze Zeit in die Fresse hält. Ach so, ich habe jetzt aber apropos Weihnachtsdoku, ich, ähm, wo kommt das eigentlich her? Ich habe nämlich zu Hause in meinem Elternhaus die VHS-Kassetten, die Schublade mal ausgeräumt, hab gesagt, so, die müssen weg, die Schublade muss leer werden, das Haus wird demnächst vielleicht nicht mehr Teilbesitz der Familie, also wird jetzt langsam schon mal ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Die VHS-Kassetten habe ich dann genommen und gesagt, ich kann die in Köln digitalisieren lassen, ist ja kein Problem. Es waren 35 Kassetten, nicht beschriftet. Oh, geil! Auf den einen sind die Skiurlaube meiner Eltern, which are hilarious. Die fangen irgendwann an, auf Tischen zu tanzen, alles ist toll, gold, goldige Aufnahmen, toll. Der andere Teil sind Weihnachtsdokumentationen, die ein bisschen so wie so National Geographic, mein Cousin und mich im Mittelpunkt haben, die beide Einzelkinder ... Sorry, sorry, sorry. Du willst mir sagen, es gibt 35 VLS mit Aufnahmen von dir als Kind, die wir jetzt im Ufo-Club auf Patreon jede Woche ein Tape veröffentlichen. Ich bin bereit, I appreciate the clickbait. Willst du mir das hier gerade sagen, dass wir den kleinen Stefan im Pyjama, der schön seinen N64 auspackt, willst du mir das sagen? Jein, es gibt ein paar Videos, wo das drauf ist. Es gibt ein Video, was wollte ich immer zur Upsi-Pan- schicken, wie ich in die Mülltonne falle, ha ha ha, alles lustig, super toll. Diese Sachen gibt es alle, auch wie ich mit meinem Cousin mich prügel, weil er jeweils meine Geschenke haben wollte an diesem einen Weihnachten und ich jeweils seine Geschenke. Besser hätte man das nicht skippen können. Ja, aber gibt es da nicht eine einfache Lösung für das Problem? Für uns nicht, weil es waren immer noch unsere Besitztümer. Geben wir die Spur mit am Spielen? Nein. Du warst doch nicht Sankt Stephan, da war der Story-Arc noch nicht beendet. Du warst ein besonders habsichtiges Kind, um dann irgendwann das Gegenteil als Heiliger zu werden. Ich verstehe schon. Ganz tolle Storytelling bei dir immer. Es gibt vier, fünf Kassetten mit coolem Wert. Der Rest ist aufgenommen auf ProSieben, Star Wars, fünf. Wow, die alte Version, die unverendete Version, das ist Gold wert, Stefan. Ich glaube nicht, dass 1995 die alte Version aufgenommen, gezeigt wurde bei ProSieben. Aber, und es wurde nicht beschriftet. Das heißt, der Zettel ist nachangekommen, wo irgendwann die VS-Kassetten wurden per se nicht beschriftet. Das heißt, es gab einen Zettel, wo die Nummern gleich, hier wurde Star Wars aufgenommen, hier wurde Flutter Karibik aufgenommen, so, dieser Zettel ist weg, heisst, ich musste alle zum Digitalisieren geben. Jetzt habe ich eine, und dann haben die mir so... Du gibst das in ein Labor weiter, oder eine Siebfügel? Nee, man gibt das ab zum Digitalisieren. Wem? Digitalisierungsfirmen, und das kostet irgendwie so sieben Euro pro Kassette, da habe ich gesagt, ja, ist arschteuer, aber kann man ja mal machen. Wie kommt das da hin, du schickst da eine Kiste hin? Das war bei mir um die Ecke lustigerweise ein Laden, ein kleiner Laden. Da bin ich hingegangen, hab die abgegeben. Und da sitzt dann jemand einfach mit so einem VHS-Recorder, steckt die erste Kassette rein, wartet zwei Stunden und dann die nächste. Aber die Color-correcten das auch ein bisschen, damit es dann wieder schick aussieht und überspielen mir das auf eine Festplatte. Die machen das alles automatisch. Aber ja, die sehen, wie ich als Baby in der Badewanne liege und hab, ich hab gar kein Problem damit. Also die beschriften das dann auch, Star Wars, Fluch der Karibik, Weihnachten, Sextape, Sextape, Sextape, Sextape, Sextape. Ach Gott, das hab ich noch gar nicht in Erwägung gezogen. Das ist das Erste, was ich in Erwägung ziehen würde. Naja, und jetzt kam dann plötzlich der Anruf, weil, dann haben die gesagt, ja, die meisten VHS dieser Art werden nicht ganz bespielt. Da ist irgendwie 70 Minuten drauf und dann berechnen wir auch nicht den vollen Preis. Ich dachte mir, ja, okay, dann lande ich irgendwo bei vielleicht 200 Euro oder sowas und das ist schon okay. Jetzt habe ich eine Rechnung bekommen, schon, ich war noch nicht da, Rechnung bekommen für 750 Euro, Was? Weil irgendwie achtze Überlänge, Überlänge, Überlänge, Überlänge hatten und irgendwie so viermal 90 Minuten, das heißt, da ist jetzt wahrscheinlich alle Star Wars Teile auf dieser fucking VHS aufgenommen worden, mit 114 Werbeblocks von ProSieben aus den 90ern, auf die ich wiederum auch ein bisschen Bock habe. Aber das ist doch das Geschäftsmodell. Aber warum rufen die dich vorher an?
Die sehen doch, wenn die die VHS ...
Weil das ja ein Geschäftsmodell ist, dass die sagen,
ja, wenn es mal dann Überlänge hat.
Die wissen ganz genau.
Ich meine, so VHS, da hat man den Rekorder dann so programmiert
und der hat dann einfach durchgehend aufgenommen.
So habe ich es auch gemacht, um natürlich die Soft-Pornos nachts mit aufzunehmen.
Anderes Thema.
Aber so waren die alle voll.
Ja, schrecklich.
Ja, und jetzt kannst du da so ein USB-Stick abholen. Jetzt habe ich allen Verwandten die Weihnachtsgeschenke wieder weggenommen, tausche die wieder um, weil ich denke, nein, das ist mir viel zu teuer. Aber jetzt, keine Ahnung, ich sammle jetzt glaube ich bei den Verwandten ein, die auch alle Bock haben auf die Videos und dann schmeiße ich zusammen und es wird, okay, es ist viel zu teuer, ich glaube, es ist auch der Geschäftsmodell, die haben nicht vorher angerufen, hätten wir ja immer machen können. Naja, jetzt habe ich drei Videos. Gibt es wieder eine Google-Rezension? Es gibt wieder eine saftige Google-Rezension. Eine sich gewaschen habende Google-Rezension. Stefan schlägt einfach Köln kurz und klein. Alles wird kaputtgeschlagen hier. Nein, eben nicht. Es wird besser gemacht. Leute sehen auf Google jetzt die Wahrheit. Es ist so viele positive Rezensionen von dir gesehen. Es ist immer nur, ich habe keinen Stuhl mehr bekommen, ich konnte mich nicht hinsetzen, ich musste mein Muffin im Stehen essen. Bereit für die Wahrheit. Und im Blaubeermuffin waren nur sieben Blaubeeren drin. Köln, wollt ihr weiterhin in einem sich beschönenden, komischen System leben, wo ihr auf Google schaut, fünf Sterne seht, in das Café geht und die schlechteste Erfahrung eures Lebens habt. Oh, da wollt ihr die Wahrheit lesen. Yo, seid ihr bereit für die Wahrheit, Köln? Yo, Kölle. Ja, das ist der Spruch von Köln, yo, Kölle. Wow, aber das ist, also das, glaube ich, macht schon Spaß. Da hätte ich Spaß dran, dass mir so nachmittags wirklich da so durchzuskippen, alte Werbungen, ja, ich hab auch Bock auf die Werbung. dieses Flimmerzeug, immer grossartig. Vielleicht sind da echte, also gerade dieses VHS, da gibt es auf Ebay, könnt ihr mal gucken, da sind VHS-Kassetten, werden gerade zu einer neuen Wertanlage, da gibt es einen grossen Hype gerade, und die kann man auch so graden lassen. Also man kennt das vielleicht von Pokémon-Karten, die schickt man irgendwo hin, und dann prüfen die die Karte, und dann geben die dir so ein offizielles Gr Grading und das machen Leute auch mit VHS-Kassetten. Gut, das sind jetzt alles bespielte, leere Kassetten, Rohlinge, aber vielleicht, wie, ist das auch was wert? Aber die, die ich jetzt dann dargegeben habe, das wäre eigentlich eine Wertanlage gewesen. Naja, ich glaube, wenn die so selber bespielt sind, nicht, wenn das dann eher so die Originalausgabe von Jurassic Park ist oder so. Auch das, glaube ich, ist natürlich eine Blase. Die Frage ist, ob das was wert ist. Aber es wird zumindest so betrieben auf Ebay, dann kannst du da mal bestellen. Anlagetipp, Florentin? VHS-Kassetten, ja. Investiert euer gesamtes Geld in VHS-Kassetten, kauft sie, lasst sie graden und dann stellt sie auf Ebay und guckt mal, ob sie jemand kauft. Ja, ich glaube, ich wurde ein bisschen gescammt, aber ist ja auch okay. Ja, gehört auch dazu. Hab ich gar nicht erzählt, aber ich wurde letztes Jahr auch noch gescammt. Irgendwie überrascht mich das nicht. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich stehe hier immer so als Vollidiot da, der irgendwie seinen Abfluss nicht auf die Reihe bekommt. Ja, weißt du was das kostet, eine stinkende Wohnung zu haben? Null Euro, null, nichts, gar nichts. Was kostet ein Klick bei dir 700 Euro?
Aber es ist ja nicht endlich verteilt, das Vollidiot-Dasein.
Das heißt, wenn ich ... Bin ich jetzt ein zu großer Vollidiot, um das zu verstehen?
Ja, nur weil ich ein Vollidiot bin,
macht das nicht so einen weniger grossen Vollidiot.
Nein, es gibt schon maximal ein Pensum Dummheit auf der Welt.
Es gibt kein endliches Dummheit, das ist nicht endlich, und das das Problem. Aber auch positiv zu sehen, Genie ist auch nicht endlich. Nehmt euer Schicksal selbst in die Hand, das ist mein Tipp für euch dieses Jahr. Ich habe ein bisschen zu viel von dieser kristalltragenden Frau mitbekommen. Ne, ich habe nämlich, dachte ich nämlich wahnsinnig lustig, habe ein YouTube-Video gesehen, wo Werbung gestaltet wurde und war dann auf der Website davon, die hieß Established Titles. Eine Website, wo man für einen guten Zweck Land kauft in Schottland. Und da wird, das war alles gesagt worden von der Werbung von diesem YouTuber, den ich mochte, da werden dann Bäume gepflanzt. Man kauft quasi ganz irgendwie einen Quadrat, weiß nicht, einen halben Quadratmeter Land in Schottland. Da wird dann ein Baum gepflanzt für einen. Das kostet irgendwie 50, 60 Dollar. Und nach altem Gesetz werden Landbesitzer in Schottland haben das Recht, sich einen Titel zu geben, nämlich Lord. Man wird Lord oder für die Frauen Lady. Das heißt, ich habe kurz gedacht, und dann gibt es auch auf der Website dann so Bilder, wie man seine Sparkassenkarte oder Kreditkarte in Lord Stephan Tietze ändern kann. Ich habe natürlich gedacht, das ist nicht nur lustig, es ist auch toll und macht die Welt zu einem besseren Ort. Wirklich mehr Adel, ist das, was wir brauchen? Ne, mehr Bäume, mehr Bäume und der andere Aspekt ist irgendwie lustig. Und dann kriegt man so eine Urkunde, wo dann bescheinigt ist, welches Landstück man gekauft hat und man ist dann Lord. Ihr habt gemerkt daran, dass ich das nie erzählt habe, dass das schon vielleicht was viel zuviel gegangen ist, weil einen Tag später, nach meinem Kauf, hat mein lieber Freund The Legal Eagle ein toller YouTube-Channel, den du auch, glaube ich, kennst. Ja, genau, ein US-amerikanischer Anwalt, der immer sehr gut Rechtssachen erklärt. Der Rechtssachen erklärt, der auch Amber Heard gegen John Depp erklärt und alles irgendwie vereinnahmarsch und verständlich hinbekommt. Und er hat gesagt, why established titles is a huge scam. Das war der Titel des Videos und meine Reaktion war, na shit. Und du mit deinem Zylinder und deinem Wrack. Mit meinem Monokel. Oh, goddammit. Oh, goddammit. Oh, is everybody mental? Becky, get the horse. Get the horse. Und das war schlimm. Also es war, ja, mal wieder wurde ich reingelegt mit meiner Leichtgörbigkeit. Aber das habe ich nicht gedacht, dass eine Firma die Leute anzieht, die unbedingt einen Titel haben wollen, dass die nicht ganz koscher ist. Bäume pflanzen ist ja auch ein Teil, den lässt du jetzt weg. Aber alle um mich herum haben schon gesagt, das ist ein Riesenscam, du bist ein Idiot. Und ich habe immer gesagt, nee, lest euch das durch, das macht schon Sinn. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass man sich legalen Lord nennen darf. Ich dachte nur, ah, vielleicht ist wirklich eine alte Tradition, alte Lord and Land Ladies können sich dann ebenso nennen. Das will ich sehen, wie du zum Kölner Amt gehst und ja, nächster. Hello, Madam. Was wollen Sie? Ich bin Stefan Michael-Tietze. Oh, may I add ... Einen Ausweis dabei? Excuse me, may I add Lord Stefan Michael-Tietze. Ja, ich habe meinen alten Ausweis dabei. Der dürfte nicht mehr gültig sein. Was wollen Sie hier machen? Und ich habe diese Urkunde, Fräulein. Denn diese Urkunde bestätigt mir durch meinen Landbesitz in Schottland, da sehen Sie neben Edinburgh, bestätigt mir meinen Lord-Titel, meine Lordschaft. Ja und jetzt? Ich würde nur gerne meinen Ausweis erinnern. Ja, das können wir so nicht machen. Ah, okay, alles bedankt. Das hat hier keine Gültigkeit. Ja, perfekt, dankeschön. Aber ich glaube, vor allem, was, es ist Schottland, ne, ging's, Schottland.
Genau. Was natürlich auch ein interessanter Aspekt ist, dass ja in Schottland man sein eigenes Kilt-Muster hat. Jeder hat sein eigenes Kilt-Muster und du kannst dir, glaube ich, wenn du so, du kannst dir irgendwo in der Und gekauft. Du kannst ja tatsächlich irgendwo in der Scottish National Kilt Archive, wo alle Kilt-Muster da sind, kannst du dir... Ist es nicht endlich? Nee, es ist nicht endlich. Also es gibt so gewisse Regeln, du hast so, glaube ich, maximal drei Farben, die müssen so und so übereinander liegen, schaut es euch an. Wie ein Fingerabdruck. Wie ein Fingerabdruck, in der weise. Und da kannst du dir auch, glaube ich, sogar für einen gewissen Preis, kannst du dich eintragen lassen in das Scottish National Archive für Kildmuster, das dann da steht. Das ist das Stefan-Tietze-Muster, das darf dann auch niemand mehr so benutzen. Und da kannst du tatsächlich vielleicht noch ein bisschen deiner schottischen Kildwürde haben. Mir ist schon aufgefallen, dass du ein Kild trägst. Ich es gar nicht da darauf ansprechen. Das ist noch übergeblieben, das ist noch so ein Rest aus dieser Fahrt. Aber ich dachte, das kommt schon noch zur Sprache irgendwann, wenn du bereit bist. Aber es ist ganz clever gemacht, auf der Website stehen also die ganzen Bilder und Überschriften, also nicht die Überschriften, also eigentlich die Schriftform macht in dem Sinne nichts falsch, die haben schon gute Anwälte am Start, der die Bilder und so, die suggerieren nur die ganze Zeit, weil da sind dann geänderte Ausweise und so. Und die Schrift ist auch sehr, sagen wir mal, irreführend, aber eigentlich einigermaßen klar abgesichert, meinte der Ligeligel, obwohl er da auch ein großes Fragezeichen hintermacht und glaubt, man könnte die auch verklagen. Und was aber das Schlimme ist, ist, dass die Podcasts und YouTuberInnen beauftragen, Werbung für sie zu machen, so wie wir auch Werbung machen. Das finde ich moralisch verwerflich, also wirklich, wer würde sowas machen? Das würde ich niemals machen. Das kommt zu wirklich, niemals. Der Aspekt kommt erst noch, der moralisch schwierig ist, Weil die ganzen Leute lesen das Briefing falsch, nicht richtig und interpretieren in diese Lücken rein, was ja auch ich als Endbenutzer auf dieser Website in diese Lücken rein interpretiere und verkaufen das dann so. Das heißt, die sagen Dinge, die legal falsch sind. Genau deswegen würde ich sowas nie machen, weil du kannst dir nie sicher sein, dass du nicht am Ende irgendwas Falsches sagst, um Leute in die Irre zu führen, ob du es jetzt willst oder nicht. Aber deswegen ist das Risiko zu hoch, weil wir sind keine Anwälte, wir kennen uns nicht gut aus, wir sind keine Verbraucherschützer. Stell dir mal vor Versicherungen. Ja, stell dir mal vor so etwas wie Versicherungen. Ja, so etwas lebenseinschneidende Entscheidungen wie Versicherungen. Das finde ich wirklich so falsch. Versicherungen oder gute Ernährung mit nachhaltigen Produkten. Naja, also dann habe ich hingeschrieben, weil man kann, wie bei allen Dingen, die man mitmacht kaufen kann, ist ja inzwischen auch verpflichtet, dass man da ein Rückgaberecht hat. Ich dachte mir, da werden die sich bestimmt auch abgesichert haben, dann habe ich geschrieben, Dear Lords and ladies, within my 60 days of bla bla bla, hätte ich gerne das stornieren und hätte gerne Refund. Und die haben sofort zurückgeschrieben, yes, hier ist ein Rückweg Refund. Da habe ich gedacht, das ist ja so krass, das ist eine Scam-Firma, die den Scam nicht nötig hat, weil so viele wahrscheinlich einfach aus Gag das behalten und verschenken das dann. Und es ist eher, niemand in der Kette ist ja interessiert, dass es nicht funktioniert oder falsch ist. Als Betrogener willst du den Betrug aufrechterhalten, weil du weiterhin Lord sein willst. Stimmt schon, ja. Du schenkst das weiter, niemand nimmt es so richtig ernst, geht auch niemand zum Amt damit. Aber wollen die Leute auch ihr Land mal irgendwann sehen? Nee, kannst du nicht, weil es gibt in dem Sinne kein Land. Die haben Land gekauft und es ist so NFT. Es gibt in dem Sinne kein Land. Was habe ich dann gekauft? Die haben sehr viel Land und man kauft quasi NFT-mäßig Codes, aber du könntest nie zu deinem Landstück gehen. Das ist sehr weird. Die haben quasi auf ihrem Server dieses Land unterteilt, und darauf kaufst du dann Anrechte und so. Also, das ist alles sehr merkwürdig. Du kaufst nie physisches Land, das ist auch noch ein Problem. Und du pflanzt auch keinen Baum. Da hätte man dann das Baum-Abo, das kostet dann aber acht Euro im Monat oder so was, auch noch hinzuklicken müssen. Ja, das kannst du ja. Und das stand ... Ja, das war ja der Grund, warum ich es eigentlich machen wollte. Nicht weil ich so eine Lor-Ratsache. Ja, so, jetzt habe ich Geld wieder jedenfalls und dachte mir, das ist ganz schön krass, dass du einen Scam entwickelst und gescamte Leute, die dahinter kommen, dem sagst, gibst du einfach das Geld zurück, damit die die Klappe halten und das nicht irgendwie einen Lawsuit starten, weil so viele immer noch quasi an diesen Scam glauben wollen oder es auch schon wissen und dann einfach akzeptieren, dass es einfach ein Gag ist und bezahlen dann irgendwie 60 Dollar für den Gag.
Kurze Frage, man hört das ja heutzutage immer häufiger, Bäume pflanzen für einen guten Zweck, man kauft irgendwas und dann wird in deinem Namen ein Baum gepflanzt oder man kompensiert seinen CO2-Ausstoß. Was genau bedeutet ein Baum einpflanzen, weil der Baum, der da eingepflanzt wird, der stand ja davor schon irgendwo anders und hat auch da ja schon CO2 aus der Luft gesaugt, um zu wachsen. Du bezahlst quasi den Diesel-Traktor, der da hinfährt, das wegmacht und den Baum dann 200 Kilometer weiter nach Edinburgh. Dem CO2-Haushalt ist ja egal, wo der steht, ob der jetzt genau da steht, wo du das gekauft hast oder wo er das gezüchtet wurde. Ich glaube, Baum pflanzen im Sinne von ... Dann da so ein Korn reinlegen. Ja, den gab es wahrscheinlich schon, aber den an den Ort, also da gibt es wahrscheinlich schon so einen kleinen Keimling. Und den pflanzen wir an den Ort, wo der auch besteht und ein großer, mächtiger Baum wird. Würde man das jetzt nicht kaufen, würde der dann einfach totgetreten werden. Genau, dann kommt da so einen Mann hin, der dann so einen Bunsenbrenner und der fackelt das dann ab. So eine Waffe einfach. So, von euch hundert Setzling wurden dreissig gekauft, das heißt siebzig, ich habe hier siebzig Kugeln. So, jetzt wollen wir mal sehen, ne? Was sind deine letzten Worte? Bam! Was ist mit dir? Bam! Bam! Bam! Wenn alle, die nicht verkauft wurden, erschossen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das nicht gut ist. Ich kann es mir nur nicht ganz genau vorstellen, was genau da passiert, aber wir brauchen alle diese Illusionen, dass das irgendwie klappt, damit wir unsere Flügel kompensieren können und ein gutes Gewissen haben. Deswegen, ich will gar gar nicht jetzt zu tief einsteigen, sondern das klappt und das ist super und das wird uns alle retten. Schaut mal die, es gibt wahrscheinlich auch gute Dokus dazu, kann man sich gut mal ein paar Artikel zu lesen, ich meine, ich habe eine spannende Dokumente darüber gesehen, über diese Greenwashing-Versuche der Airlines und so und was, wo genau das Geld hinfließt und sowas, das ist, ja, muss man sich Gedanken machen, was ist die Alternative, das wenige Geld, was davon dann wirklich effektiv genutzt wird, auch nicht zu bezahlen, I don't know. Wie ist es denn, also du hast, wenn du jetzt mehrere Titel hast, weil du bist ja schon fast Sankt Stefan. Ich bin immer noch Tietze Tietze, also das war ja auch noch mein Fehler mit dem Ausweis. Also da gibt es ja bestimmt Ich bin Captain, Lord, Stefan, Michael, Tietze Tietze, Sankt, ah ja, Sankt Tietze Tietze. Also da gibt es ja bestimmt, also das waren ja Dinge, über die man wahrscheinlich früher wirklich nachgedacht hat, wenn du gleichzeitig Ser bist, aber auch ein Herzog oder was auch immer oder Kaplan oder Bischof, dann muss es ja so eine Reihenfolge geben, wo man das sagt oder was dann wichtiger ist. Also gerade bin ich nur Sankt Stephan, es wird dann schwierig. Ist es durch jetzt oder was vom Vatikan? Ja, Lord habe ich abgegeben. Habe ich ja wieder zurückgeschickt, der Mail. Du hast ja richtig gute Kontakte zu Ratzinger, der löst das für dich. Ja, genau, also das ist mein Best Buddy und das wird ja alles. Und da wendest du dich mit dem? Ja, ich würde mich jetzt, es liegt alles bei ihm und mit ihm bin ich total gut. Ja, perfekt. Und deswegen ist es total, also eigentlich steht ihm nichts mehr im Wege, nur noch seine Unterschrift. Ja, das lohnt sich doch total, dass du im gleichen Ort aufgewachsen bist, wie er. Ihr seid zusammen irgendwie immer Tennis spielen zu gehen. Zur Grundschule gegangen. Und da ich immer gut verstanden. Ist doch super. Ist ja auch in gewisser Weise ein Wunder, wenn ein Papst neben dir wohnt. Es ist so krass, weil ich hätte ja gar keine ... Ich habe niemanden, there is no way in für mich, aber ich kenne halt ihn gut. Über ein paar Ecken, ich habe nicht zusammen mit ihm Tennis gespielt, aber ich kenne ihn gut ein paar Ecken. Und deswegen, der Sankt-Stefan-Titel ist mir absolut sicher, der wird schon garantiert. Du hast ihn jetzt quasi schon in Ausweis aufgenommen. Genau, er liegt schon bei ihm auf seinem Schreibtisch, auf seinem ausweisgroßen Schreibtisch. Und es ist jetzt noch wirklich eine Frage, er muss nur noch unterschreiben und zurückschicken. Darauf warte ich jetzt noch, ich habe ein paar Tage nichts von ihm gehört. Aber da steht ihm überhaupt nichts mehr, er hat mir noch einen Smiley geschickt, so ein Thumbs-up-Smiley. Cool, so ein betenden Smiley. Ja, ja, cool. Ja, ist doch super. Nee, ist doch toll. Schön für dich, dass das klappt. Dann kannst du jetzt 23-Entrich richtig durchstarten als Sankt Stephan. Aber dann ist die Frage, wenn ich dann ein Schiff hab, irgendwann mal Captain, ne, dann ist schon schwierig. Sankt-Captain oder Captain Sankt Stephan? Captain Sankt Stephan klingt eigentlich besser als Sankt-Captain oder Captain-Sankt-Stefan? Captain-Sankt-Stefan klingt eigentlich besser als Sankt-Captain-Stefan. Captain-Sankt-Stefan. Captain-Sankt-Stefan. Ja, ja. Kann sein so, Stefan. Captain-Stefan. Oh, sorry, Captain-Stefan. Captain-Sankt-Stefan. Das hätten Sie mir am ersten Mal sagen können. Das Szene dauert drei Minuten lang. Flut der Griming Teil neun. Ja. Ja es genauso rapide Bergab gebe, den Film, wäre das eine völlig erwartbare Szene. Aber gibt es das nicht. Ich glaube, es kommt wieder mehr. Wie? Ich glaube, es geht noch weiter mit Pirates of the Caribbean sechs. 2024 kommt Teil sechs raus. Wir freuen uns alle drauf, nachdem wir jetzt natürlich den Riesenkracher Avatar 2 gesehen haben im Kino, freuen wir uns auf weitere Fortsetzungen. Weitere Fortsetzungen, immer mehr hoch mit den Zahlen. Mehr vom Gleichen, mehr vom Gleichen, den Schlechter. Hoch mit den Zahlen. Ja, mehr vom Gleichen, den Schlechter, wo mehr Geld für ausgegeben wurde, mehr davon. Haben ja alle gesagt, dass Avatar 2 technisch wahnsinnig gut aussieht visuell, fand ich irgendwie nicht, also ich weiß nicht, irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie nur an mir lag, aber dass sie auch irgendwie so teilweise so halbtransparent waren und irgendwie so ganz schlecht aus, so ganz schlecht freigestellt und hatte nicht das eine Kind die ganze Zeit so ein Shutterstock-Wasserzeichen im Gesicht, ich fand das total merkwürdig. Ja, wir haben die auch genannt, Shutter. Ja, aber warum? Das war so der letzte Weg, das zu retten, diesen Fehler. Kann man nicht bei so einer riesen Hollywood-Produktion da irgendwie so ein bisschen... Du hast halt teilweise wirklich noch so die Maus halt im Bild gehabt. Wo ich denke, also kann man das nicht... Also dem Cursor im Bild die ganze Zeit. Teilweise war das so ein Screen Grab vom Programm, wo man es animiert hat, Premiere Scream Grab.
Ja, ja.
Und dann stelle ich Fehlermeldungen, irgendwie konnte nicht geladen werden, und dann die Maus klickt es weg.
Ich dachte mir, was ist denn hier los?
Und dann, was ich auch nicht verstanden habe, ab und zu bei offensichtlich animierten Sequenzen war ein Mikro im Bild.
Ja, das ist auch komisch.
Ja, aber dann, wenn ihr da schon reinkieht, dieses Mikro, was ihr nicht braucht in einem animierten Film, dann macht es auch wenigstens wieder rau. Und vor allem dieses Flug-Alien hing dann an Seilen, die an den Bäumen hingen, die aber auch animiert sind. Wo ich mir denke, also muss das sein, dass das dann so rumschwingt? Aber Story war toll. Muss das? Story war richtig geil. Story war toll. Boah, ey, ich wurde hin und her gerissen, ich war emotional so involviert und wow, also ich hab... Alles noch nie, also alles was passiert, habe ich so noch nie gesehen. Unfassbar. Unfassbar. Aber die Technik war mau. Maue Technik, fantastische Story. Und ich finde, und zu kurz fand ich den. Viel zu kurz. Wie lange war der, fünf Minuten, sechs Minuten oder so? Also für mich hätte der gut und gerne noch drei Stunden gehen können. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Weil es hat sich angefühlt wie sechs Minuten. Also ich dachte mir, hä, ich habe mich noch gerade hingesetzt. Ich hatte fast eine volle Popcorn-Tüte in der Hand, als der Film zu Ende war. Und ich dachte mir, bleibt man jetzt sitzen, bis man es aufgegessen hat? Geht man mit dem Popcorn in der Hand raus? Was passiert jetzt? Ich habe ungelogen irgendwann angefangen zu schwitzen bei diesem Film und habe so eine Panik gehabt, so eine, ich muss hier raus. Und jetzt hatte ich, aber bei einem Film hatte ich das schon mal. Das ist Wasser, Stefan. Das ist kein Schweiß. Du warst so involviert. Aquaphobic. Bei einem Film hatte ich das schon mal, das war Mother von Darren Aronofsky, weil er so intensiv war. Und da wurde dann irgendwann das Baby gegessen haben, diese Menschenrasse. Das war ein Film, da sind viele auch aufgestanden und gegangen, wo ich auch schon mal so einen kalten Schweiß aus der Haut hatte. Da und bei Avatar 2. The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water. So, welcher Film darf sein? The Way of the Water. The Way of the Water Water. Aber ja, auch tolle Sätze wie Must protect my family oder I'm the man, I have to protect my wife oder das sind so, die werden uns ewig in Erinnerung bleiben, diese ganzen Sätze. Ja, also so viele Zitate, ich glaube, ich rede eigentlich, ich rede, seitdem ich den Film gesehen habe nur noch in Avatar 2 Zitaten. Ja, genau. Man hat so viele schmissige Zitate. Es macht auch keinen Sinn, wenn du sagst, der Weitflügler muss raus, schieß den Weitflügler ab. They're blue now, they're blue now, they're blue now. Also das sind Zitate, die einfach bleiben. Grossartig. Ja, Herr Hauder hat dann auf den Himmel geschaut, hat mich eingegrenzt und hat gesagt, it's blue now, it's blue now. Ach, toll, grossartig. Aber Popcorn ist schon lecker, ne? Also kann man nicht sagen, dass das so lecker ist. Unser lieber Freund Jermaine Clement und der lustigsten Performer. Super. Wow, lustig und toll, toller Typ gewesen, toller Charakter, den er da gespielt hat. Super. Allein deswegen könnt ihr schon mal ins Kino sehen. Jetzt tatsächlich ungelogen, weil das die weirdeste ... Ich weiss nicht, wo du bist. Ich weiss auch nicht mehr, welche Ebene wir gerade sind. Aber achtet mal auf Jermaine Clement, einer der arguably lustigsten Menschen auf diesem Planeten in Avatar 2. Allein deswegen ... Schon undankbar, oder, für die Schauspieler, wenn die da immer diese blauen Leute spielen. Du denkst ja doch, ich bin in einem erfolgreichsten ... Das ist ja der erfolgreichste Film aller Zeiten. Casablanca, Star Wars, Indiana Jones, E.T., Willow, nichts war erfolgreich. Und du spielst mit und läufst durch die Strasse und suchst den Augenkontakt mit Leuten und so, ne? Und also, was? Also soll ich ja, was, also, weil Sie sich fragen, ich habe in Avatar 2 mitgespielt. Ja. Ach so. Ja gut, die sind ja blau. Waren Sie eine der Blauen oder eine der Soldaten? Ne, ich war einer der blauen. Ah, okay, die erkennt man ja nicht.
Naja, also es gibt ja schon gewisse Gesichtsgeber.
Gehen Sie mal jetzt aus der Schwange raus.
Nein, aber Entschuldigung.
Sie drängen sich auch vor.
Nein, Sie haben ja gefragt, weil Sie haben ja nicht gefragt, woher Sie mich kennen.
Nein, Sie haben mich gefragt, kennen Sie mich nicht irgendwoher.
Antwort auf Ihre Frage.
So, ihr kennt Grande Latte Macchiato. Grande. Warum arbeiten Sie jetzt bei Starbucks? Das ist echt schwierig, ne? Das ist so wie damals Gollum, so Andy Serkis als Gollum. Andy Serkis. Und es ist auch so... Ja. Der hat halt Gollum gespielt. Aber der war ja, der war am Set. Und dann noch mit dem Studio. Und hat dann noch mal im Studio gezappelt. Schwierig. Ja, ich habe auch jetzt noch mal Polar Express, Making-of geschaut, wie alle, selbst die Kinder auch von Tom Hanks gespielt werden. Und man denkt auch beim Gucken, ich habe das hier für nie gesehen, aber den Trailer schon,
früher als Kind habe ich ihn wahrscheinlich wirklich mal gesehen,
aber es gab so eine große Diskussion darüber,
warum der so seltsam animiert ist.
Und ich glaube, es liegt auch manchmal unabhängig von
dem schlechten Stil, diesen toten Augen,
auch daran, dass Tom Hanks einfach
alle Kinder spielt und Kinder einen anderen
Ausdruck haben als ein erwachsener Mann,
der Schauspieler ist und
wahnsinnig viel mit einem Gesicht machen kann.
Und diese Kinder haben viel zu viel
Muskelbewegung in dem Gesicht.
Weird, weird.
Gruseliger Film.
Es ist so ein gruseliger Film.
Und inhaltlich die Fahrer mit dem Zug und dann immer,
oh, da hängt jetzt irgendwas vor dem Zug, wir müssen ihn retten.
Oh, da ist das Ticket weggefallen.
Ja, Leute,
fahrt da doch hin, Mann, schneidet das doch
aus, mir egal.
Fahrt doch einfach da hin. Ich hab das Gefühl, ich sehe nur die Probleme von den Dingen, die passiert sind. Ich sehe nur die Obstacles, ich will doch keine Obstacles sehen. Ich will das doch nicht sehen. Aber ich frage mich echt, wie das ist, wenn das heutige Kinder schauen, das ist doch ein Gruselfilm, oder? Polar Express animierter Film mit Tom Hanks, also gerade wenn man so gutes CGI gewohnt ist CGI gewohnt ist. Ja genau, weil wir es noch nicht gewohnt waren. Weil wir damit aufgewachsen sind mit Playstation 1 Grafik und denken immer noch, das ist die Revolution. Es gab wirklich einen Zeitpunkt, wo man falsch lag. Also wo, weil ich behaupte nämlich, jetzt liegen wir nicht falsch. Im Sinne von, damals haben wir GTA Vice City gespielt auf der PS2. Fotorealistisch. Und gedacht, das ist Fotorealismus. Nee, aber wirklich. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir Fotorealismus gesagt hätten. Du hättest bestimmt Fotorealistisch. Alter, das sieht krass aus wie unser Leben. Das sieht aus wie Leben. Das bin ich quasi. Das bin ich quasi. In Miami fahre ich rum mit Mustang und habe gute Zeit. Aber so habe ich damals gesprochen. Und heute würde man ja schon sagen, ja klar, unsere Bildschirme schaffen mit 4K und UHD und was haben wir jetzt 6K, schaffen einen gewissen Fotorealismus. Und da glaube ich nicht, dass wir in 20 Jahren zurückblicken und sagen, wir waren bescheuert. Nein, das ist dumm. Wir liegen immer falsch. Wir liegen immer falsch. Wir liegen immer falsch. Immer. Bei was noch? Immer rückblickend, also du guckst doch nie auf eine vergangene Epoche zurück und sagst, ja, die haben das besser verstanden als wir. Die hatten bessere, also welche Epoche hatte denn bessere Bilder und Kunst und so, also gut, das ist natürlich jetzt subjektiv und so, aber guck dir mal diese mittelalterliche Malerei an und die dachten ja auch, Alter, das ist mega geil, das ist richtig viel wert. Das war auch mega geil. Ja, damals war es geil, aber heute nicht. Doch, ich finde, damals wurde richtig geil gemalt. Ja, wirklich? War ein tolles Argument. Hm, anderer Meinung. Ja, nee, aber ich, doch, teilweise wurde es schon sehr toll, photoistisch gemalt und so. Naja, naja, Kunst, auch Musik, würde ich auch ein großes Fragezeichen machen, ob immer alles besser wäre. Schwierig. Aber ja, da ist schon ein Punkt. Klar, technisch und wissenschaftlich gesehen sowieso. Aber das war wirklich komisch, dass wir da alle falsch lagen. War merkwürdig, dass es in uns gefahren ist. Es war einfach besser als alles, was wir bisher gesehen hatten. Vielleicht auch mit mehr Fantasie. Du füllst dann die Lücken selber, wenn du so einen klotzigen Mario siehst, denkst du, Alter, wie krass. Das ist ein Klempner, sieht aus wie ein italienischer Klempner. Und da kommt die Mutter rein und sagt, was macht dieser italienische Klempner bei dir in der Woche? Was macht der ja? Hol den aus dem Fernseher raus, Jochen, bitte, da steckt ein Mensch im Fernseher drin! Ja, genau wie mein Opa, der mal dachte, dass Dortmund spielt. Aber mein Cousin und ich haben nur FIFA gespielt und Dortmund hat 8 zu 0 verloren. Gegen Kamerun. Gegen Dortmund. Und er hat gesagt, what the fuck is happening und ist zu seinem Schreibtisch gegangen und wir haben nur so ein Pfff ein aber da habe ich, in dieser Welt will ich nicht mehr leben, wo Kamerun gegen Botswana verliert. Ach ja. Dortmund verliert gerade gegen Kamerun zwei acht zu null, sie spielen in Mailand, Die spielen aber drei Minuten und gehen 20 zu null aus. Es steht neun zu null, es ist die zwölfte Minute angebrochen. Das ist gemein. Nein, aber es war wirklich tatsächlich so, er hat das geglaubt. Und wir hatten Spaß, aber das war merkwürdig. Ja, aber ist vielleicht ... Wobei, ich hab das Gegenteil mal gehört, dass Leute mal ihren Opa geprankt haben, indem sie ein echtes Spiel geschaut haben und dann mit Controllern da gesessen haben. Ah, finde ich auch gut. Und der Opa hat's auch geglaubt. Der hat gedacht, krass, die Grafik wird immer krasser. Ja, ja. Wohingegen mein Opa gesagt hat, wow, ich glaube, ich werde zu alt für diesen Planeten. Wie der da so ganz schnell hin und her zuckelt, die Sportler heutzutage, das ist ja auch krass, was sie können. Wie bei einer Wand glitschen in der Bande. Ja. Ah ja, ihr merkt, wir machen 2023 genauso weiter wie letztes Jahr. Ja, das war unser Vorsatz, nichts zu verändern. Nichts zu verändern. Gar nichts, wir verändern überhaupt nichts, wir machen genauso weiter und manchmal muss man auch einfach weiter geradeaus fahren. Um zu merken, dass man die ganze Zeit auf dem falschen Weg war. Ja, es gibt auch manche geradeaus Jahre einfach, die man weiterführt. Aber es wird einige Highlights geben 2023 und auf die freuen wir uns ganz besonders. Ja, nenn mir zwei. Neue T-Shirts. Oh yes! Ja, ja, ja. Nee, es wird richtig cool. Demnächst haben wir eine kleine, coole Aktion mit euch vor im Merch-Shop. Also, stay tuned dafür. Im Merch-Mai. Merch-Mai. Schaut dafür mal ... Nein, das war jetzt einfach nur Unsinn. Jetzt geht nicht zu Legal Eagle oder zum Legal Beagle oder irgendwo anders hin. Schaut mal auf den Patreon-Club, das Unsere Supporters Club, der Pufu-Club rein und schaut mal, da gibt es auch immer viele kleine Perks zum Beispiel, dass die Folge einen Tag herkommt, ohne Werbung genießbar ist und ihr kriegt Rabatt auf den Merchshop, wo bald was passiert, zwinker, zwinker. Ansonsten mal gucken, vielleicht gibt es uns beide in anderer Form dieses Jahr noch mal irgendwo zu sehen. Das wird ganz spannend.
Ja, zwinker. Ansonsten, mal gucken, vielleicht gibt es uns beide in anderer Form dieses Jahr noch mal irgendwo zu sehen. Das wird ganz spannend. Bleibt abzuwarten, bleibt abzuwarten, bleibt abzuwarten, bleibt abzuwarten, Escort Service. Vielleicht. Mal gucken. Wir stehen einfach nur in so einem Museum. Und stehen für den Menschen. Wir stehen für den Menschen. In die anderen Thaler, dann kommt wieder die Wörterentwicklung, Wikinger. Ja, stimmt, genau. Und der moderne Mensch. Wir haben ja da jetzt irgendeinen Schauspieler, der da steht den ganzen Tag. Und das würden wir auch gerne einen Tag machen. Wir sind das, wir stehen daneben. Ich würde stellvertretend gerne für den Mensch sein. Ich meine, es wurde ja diese eine Scheibe ins All geschossen, wo Bilder von Menschen drauf sind. Wer waren diese Leute? Wer waren diese Leute? Der Typ, der bei Wikipedia ist, oder nicht? Stimmt, wer ist der Mensch Mensch? Karl von Linné. Wer ist das? Ein Adliger, natürlich. Das ist wieder der Standardmensch. Ja. Du, Clara, ganz kurz eine Frage. Wir würden gerne da so eine Platte ins All schiessen, an die Aliens. Und da wollten wir Bilder gerne drauf machen von Menschen. Und da haben wir jetzt, haben wir an dich gedacht, dass du sozusagen stellvertretend für alle Menschen stehst. Nee, nee. Warum denn nicht? Nee, dann sind die Aliens nicht. Nee, und dann kommen die auf die Erde und dann bin ich irgendwie dann direkt das Ziel von allen, überhaupt nicht. Ich bin ja nur HR-Frau. Ich möchte das nicht so gern. Nein, aber ... Nee, ich will nicht so gern. Ich meine, für viele fände das wahrscheinlich eine große Ehre, aber für mich nicht, weil ich hab das Gefühl, wenn die Aliens kommen, dann sehen die mich und erkennen die mich als Göttin, als die krasse Anführerin des Planetens oder so was. Ja, aber das ist nicht gut? Nee, da habe ich Verantwortung, da muss ich mitnehmen, reden, ich habe nächstes Jahr voll viel vor, ich will reisen, ich bin drei Wochen in Peru und viel Backpacking und so und nee. Und mein Freund ist jetzt auch irgendwie, hat gerade einen neuen Job, er wird auch viel zu tun. Wir finden leider gar niemand anderen. Niemand anderen, weil es gibt acht Milliarden andere Menschen, es gibt wie gesagt acht Milliarden Möglichkeiten. Wir haben niemand anderen gefunden, wir müssen eigentlich, also wie viel habt ihr gefragt, weil... Wir haben fast eingebracht, also wenn wir dich nicht kriegen, dann haben wir halt gar nichts halt leider. Mit einem Filter, mit einem schönen Filter. Mit so einer Hundenase. Ja nee, das können wir, also das geht glaube ich dann nicht. Ja so oder nicht, so oder dann lass das. Ach Ach Gott, von mir. Wumm, wumm, wumm. Überall Aliens und Alien-Gans in der Fresse. Seien wir mal ehrlich, wir sind eh nicht die restriktabelste Abteilung bei der NASA. Also ich will nicht sagen, dass es scheißegal ist, was wir machen. Dafür haben wir ja als einzigen eine goldene Schallplatte an der Wand. Ja, von den Black-Eyas. Willst du die nochmal auflegen? Auf. Gar keinen Fall will ich die auflegen. I got a feeling. Komm, einmal noch. Tonight's gonna be a good night. Damit war es gut. Tonight's gonna be a good night. Bis nächste Woche. Good night. Ich wünschen euch eine gute, Leute. Haut rein.
Auf geht's mal weiter.
Das ist jetzt unsere neue Verabschiedung.
I hate this already.
Macht's gut, Leute. Wir steigen ein. Macht's gut, ciao.
It's a worst production.